james brown is probably the one guest i
was
most excited about because
it's just where i grew up james brown
was a big hero in my community it really
felt like the beatles were walking in
when james brown walked in the legendary
one of the greatest recording artists of
all time
mr james brown i place you and i'm not
just kissing your ass cause you're here
one of the top three of all time really
i got a man that they got a better count
than that
i love the guy as a guest number one
james brown
had a uh a deep thick southern accent by
the way your hair looks great
i always figured by this age you would
be bothered yes
you got all your own hair back your boy
and i'm i'm cool on you
and robin no mr brown you have all your
own hair james
oh no no mr brown don't do that
james brown was a perfectionist he was a
musical genius
and he was you know legendarily tough on
his band the people who played for him
but one time we had him come in the
[Music]
studio
uh gary was playing trumpet and a couple
of the guys were playing instruments
papa's got a brand new bag
and james brown was such a good sport
and he's so particular about musicians i
thought maybe he'd take
gary and throw him out a window because
gary plays the trumpet horribly barely
plays it
but james brown was like really into it
and he worked with gary he even gave
gary tips
on how to play the trumpet better that's
right
let me tell you what you did i did
everything wrong you know i did the
hardest thing you can do
you try to play the melody you should
play the difference
i'm working on getting better but don't
worry about playing the melody okay
don't play them out of that
too i know i don't break it up and play
those cards and break them up
great guy super [ __ ] talented i still
listen to his music all the time it's
legendary and it will live forever
and i miss him i really do
[Music]
papa's got a brand new bag
all right
i can't believe he did that